anyway remember the times actually got
there Pulitzer Prize for spreading these
outright lies they should definitely
give it back correct the record and
apologize but don't expect that to
happen the New York Times is not truly a
news organization it's basically a PR
operation for Biden and the Democratic
party all right now in the hot seat we
have the co-host of the five Geraldo
Rivera along with senior advisor to
president Trump Stephen A Miller I I
I'll agree with you Geraldo on the
surface I don't think the documents are
going to bring down Joe Biden I don't
think it's going to hurt Donald Trump if
it didn't hurt Hillary everyone's
getting away with classified top secret
documents that's not my issue
I want to know why they found these
documents on November 2nd and didn't
inform the public until 68 days later in
the interim during that 68-day interval
they also set up a special prosecutor
for Donald Trump and they also went and
visited the Penn Biden Center and they
didn't tell anybody yes they went to
Biden's home after they found documents
there but there wasn't the big you know
there wasn't the siren the raid the
kicking everybody out like they did
Donald Trump they went to the Rehoboth
home but they allowed Joe Biden to go to
that home 10 days prior knowing they
needed to look at that home and I want
you to look and talk to this audience
directly and you tell me if that sounds
like equal justice an equal application
of our laws and whether or not you want
Hunter Biden to have access to top
secret classified information
that's a different issue the hunter
Biden story that will work its way out
we are talking about this document
Scandal this is a phony Scandal Sean the
documents at Mar-A-Lago was a phony raid
it had nothing to do with the American
people there is zero evidence that
either President Biden or former
president Trump did anything to
compromise National Security is that
point
over a story that does not matter but
you're not answering my question
by Reed Mar-A-Lago but they don't rate
any of Biden's homes why is it they
didn't tell the American people for 68
days why didn't they tell us before the
election when they knew six days before
the election do you think that's fair
does that fundamentally fair to the
American people
I believe that what is happening now
with Joe Biden in part
consciously or or subconsciously is a
reflection of the authorities the the
Department of Justice attempting to show
the American people that they are being
even-handed see we rated now let's raid
Biden should the American people before
November 8th in the midterm they knew
that he had the documents
by by that that's this that was so in
its infancy this whole story was so much
in its infancy
to hold the press conference before the
midterms and say oh by the way the FBI
is going to raid my house
documents is absurd Stephen Miller is
that fair
no this was a cover-up a concealment to
try once again to influence the American
electoral process it's what we have been
seeing now for six years the Deep State
the Department of Justice now the
National Archives are trying to play God
in our elections to decide whether
Republicans win or whether Democrats
when this information was kept from the
American people to try to influence the
outcome of the election I'll say one
more thing you cannot divorce this
scandal from the fact that Hunter Biden
as you discussed with Senator Ted Cruz
is engaged in dealings with foreign
governments and the money that Hunter
Biden is earning is then subsidizing the
lifestyle of Joe Biden so we have to
know we must know how is this classified
information that was true to line if I
was traveling positive
if that was true isn't there a U.S
attorney that has been probing Hunter
Biden now for a couple of years at least
has he not come up with anything this is
a story that exists is this is a media
story this is you got my guy Trump now
I'm going to get your guy Biden I think
of far more interest right now Sean and
you alluded to it and it's one of the
things that Stephen Miller and I uh rare
things that we agree on is that Russia
gate was a phony Scandal
well that's a good opportunity because
agreement is important to say that
Russian three of us Russian gate not
only is a is in a massive Scandal but
the fact that the Columbia journalism
review as Sean said a left-wing
publication came out today and condemned
the New York Times and other
Publications I agree this is a moment
this is a moment
I want to ask the last question when you
look at the the astronomical amount of
money that the bidens made and Joe
Biden's lie that he never talked to a
hunter or any family member about their
Farm business dealings you know it's a
lie Geraldo and you look at I'll take
I'll pick three countries Ukraine where
he admits he had no experience and made
Millions Russia Millions no experience
China 1.5 billion deal Bank of China 5
million dollar uh no interest for
givable loan hundred thousand dollar
shopping spree uh you look at these
countries hostile to America did Hunter
Biden does it not stink to high heaven
the millions of dollars that he and his
family made do you not see this as a
serious need to see a serious need for
investigation for influence peddling
here
if it is true then why the hell happened
the U.S attorney told us over two years
now that they have been probing Hunter
Biden that he's more than just a junkie
or a Monger or all the other
things demonstrate
his shameful tapes
but it's a Steve Miller that's a lot of
money not National Security
they're Walling off the influence
pedaling just like they do with Hillary
because the Deep State wants the
influence peddling to continue because
when they leave government that's how
they get rich that's why it's called the
swamp
because we can't focus on the fact that
right now Russia gate is being exposed
for all the world to see that we agree
on Geraldo you are 100 right was the the
malignancy
I agree but on the issue of money that's
where they go that's where the Biden
family has the greatest vulnerability
millions and millions with no experience
what a great world it is for the bidens
I'll tell you that all right thank you
both hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else